Bob FASS has been described as the
father of freeform radio and more
poetically maybe as the Midwife at the
birth of the counterculture his radio
program radio unnameable that has run
for decades now allowed him to both bear
witness to the birth of the
counterculture but also to help
facilitate its birth what really excites
me about bringing the Bob fast
collection to Columbia and digitizing it
is that we are adding one of the most
legendary and pioneering voices in
freeform radio to our collections
Columbia University acquired the fast
archive in the spring of 2016 it
includes some 600,000 minutes of audio
that includes appearances by people like
Dylan Abbie Hoffman Allen Ginsberg
hunter s thompson and Timothy Leary
unfortunately unlike a paper archive
that lasts for decades or centuries even
the audio tape and media of any kind is
much more ephemeral so it's imperative
that we digitize and then preserve the
resulting digital file some of these
tapes are now decades old they've
already launched surpassed their
expected lifespan and so it's a crucial
priority that we do this soon to
preserve these unique audio recordings
for the future it's really not up to me
to determine how it will be used our job
is to preserve and catalog the
collection and then invite scholars and
students to ask their own questions for
historians this direction also provides
a unique window into some of the most
important political events of the 1960's
and 1970's from the uprising of students
here at Columbia University in 1968 to
the Attica prison rebellion Watergate
Bob FASS was on the air through all of
these events often he was on the scene
himself and for almost every one of
these historically crucial moments he
had callers from the scene describing
what was happening and those voices if
we don't save them now in this
digitization program will be lost for